ستستلم مقاتلات سوخوي خمسة
وثلاثين روسية الصنع بعد ثلاثة
ايران انه بدأ اضرابا عن الطعام
للفت انتباه الرئيس الامريكي جو
الى تسوية مقبولة من الطرفين.
الاحداث والتطورات. المبعوث
ان يتصاعد بين السويد وبلاده اذا
ما فشلت ستوكهولم في اتخاذ
العام لجامعة الدول العربية احمد
ابو الغيط ان الصين تقف موقفا
الصين تدعم بثبات القضية العادلة
للشعب الفلسطيني. ليرد الامين
شان دونج مجموعة من تدريبات
المواجهة في بحر الصين والتي
تهديدات امنية مع تزايد المخاوف
القادمة من الصين وكوريا
الانتقادات بسبب وضع الجيش
الالماني غير اللائق في ظل
للصين يبدأ المنافسة الحقيقية.
نعم انها امريكا لتلوح واشنطن
النتائج. حيث كانت وزيرة الدفاع
الالمانية كريستينا لامبريخت
يؤكد ان موسكو تعمل على اتفاقيات
لادخال نظام الاعفاء من التأشيرة
الطريقة يا ترى? هنا نائب وزير
الخارجية الروسي جيني ايفانوف
مفاوضات اخرى لكن عن طريق مجموعة
فاغنر قاتل الى جانبنا واحصل على
الى سلاح المفاوضات وكل يفاوض
بطريقته الخاصة. حيث اعلنت
مساعدة من الولايات المتحدة. جيش
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي يعلن مقتل
ان محادثة بوتين ووزيره تعد
تسيير عمل وهي طبيعية. لننتقل
فلاديمير بوتين وفقد اعصابه لكن
ليس على البنتاجون والغرب وانما
جهود التوصل اتفاق سلام. اعلن
مواطن امريكي محتجز في سجون
لجنة الامن القومي في البرلمان
الايراني شريان حيدري ان بلاده
اشهر وذلك بموجب الصفقة المبرمة
مع موسكو. رئيس اركان جيش الكيان
الاممي الى اليمن يصل الى
العاصمة اليمنية صنعاء لتعزيز
كل سيارات امريكا ستكون كهربائية
خلال اثني عشر عاما. البر والبحر
والجو هي مناطق الهجوم الروسية
واوكرانيا هي الضحية. فهل حان
الدبابات القتالية ومدرعات خفيفة
منها
غيرت دول الحيف الحليفة
لاوكرانيا توجهاتها متجاهلة
للنايتو مصرحا نحن في مرحلة
حاسمة من الحرب. لذلك من المهم
ينضم لركب المساعدات العسكرية
ليعلن توسيع تدريب الجنود
وفنلندا اذا لم تسلما الارهابيين
فلن يوافق على شروطهما وستزداد
فماذا عن العرب انفسهم. التهديد
التركي الخطير. ليس كل من اراد
رأى المتحدث باسم الرئاسة
التركية ابراهيم دالن ان لا
على انه سيتحتم عليهما في نهاية
المطاف التفاوض من اجل التوصل
عسكرية. قال جون كيري المبعوث
الامريكي الاسبق لشؤون المناخ ان
باستخدام قدراتها النووية للدفاع
عن اليابان حال واجهت طوكيو
تطورات الحرب الاوكرانية. الصين
تتحالف مع العرب. المنافس الاول
تحاكي عمليات قتال واقعية خصوصا
بعد ان دخلت مجموعة من حاملة
لا تكتفي بالاسلحة بل انها تجمع
الحلفاء وزير الخارجية الصيني شي
واسعة في صربيا. نعم. صربيا
الدولة الاوروبية. فهل تنجح هذه
احد جنوده واصابة ثلاثة بجروح
جراء انفجار قنبلة داخل قاعدة
الحقيقي. وهو الضغوطات الخارجية
لزيادة الدعم لتتعرض لوابل من
الشمالية. الرد الصيني جاء
باجراء حاملة الطائرات الصينية
طريق التفاوض ينجح ولا كل من
يأتي بالحرب ينتصر. وتركيا تسلك
ليعلن المجلس القومي في بلاروسيا
استعداد مسك للرد على اي استفزاز
وكيفية احباط اي هجوم محتمل.
والرسالة تصل لكييف والغرب. نعم
البحر الاسود بغواصة وخمس حاملات
طائرات خلال الساعات الماضية
تهديد وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي
المنتهية ولاية بعمل عسكري وقائي
الاسرائيلي سنهاجم المنشآت
النووية الايرانية حتى بدون
ضد برنامج ايران النووي في غضون
عامين او ثلاثة اعوام اعلن عضو
بالتجسس في بلد باتت احكام
الاعدام السمة الغالبة فيه. بعد
والتي كانت قد قدمت استقالتها
رسميا لتكشف اليوم عن السبب
بايدن ليتحرك للافراج عنه وهي
خطوة تعكس مخاوف المواطن المتهم
العربية السعودية وعدد من الدول
الاخرى ومن حرب التفاوض الى حصد
روسيا ولا اوكرانيا يمكنهما
الانتصار في الحرب عسكريا مشددا
بالتهديد والقوة فهناك دائما
طريق اخر وانقرة تعلم ذلك. حيث
بينما خرج المتحدث باسم
الكريملين ديمتري بيسكوف ليوضح
ان خطة التدريب تشمل في البداية
خمس جندي اوكراني في المانيا
اليابانيين. والصين ترد من
الاراضي العربية. اردوغان للسويد
اللحظة الاخيرة عملية تبادل
مقررة لاسرى بينما تجري روسيا
توترات العلاقات بين تركيا
وبينهما. لكن ما كل شيء ياتي
اجراءات جدية ازاء حزب العمال
الكردستاني. قائلا ان السويد
على اي استفزاز. هكذا صرحت بها
موسكو ومنسك وروسيا تحشد قوة
الهيئة الاوكرانية التي تتعامل
مع ملف الاسرى ان روسيا الغت في
تصدت لمحاولات روسية للتقدم في
محور باخموت. وها هو البنتاجون
عادلا بحق الشعب الفلسطيني في
دولة مستقلة عاصمتها القدس اصحاب
العيون الضيقة يتقربون للعرب من
خلال قضيتهم الحساسة فلسطين
جميع الطرق لكن النتائج لا زالت
ضبابية يا سادة. ليرجح اردوغان
الاوكرانيين على القتال في ساحة
المعركة ضد القوات الروسية موضحا
على وزير الصناعة في بلاده. وكان
ذلك في اول اجتماع للحكومة هذا
جون خلال زيارته لمصر ان الصين
احرص على اقامة علاقات
استراتيجية مع الدول العربية
مشيرا في الوقت نفسه الى ان
الطائرات الامريكية الضاربة
للمنطقة حسب جلوبال تايمز. بكين
للمواطنين الروس الذين يسافرون
الى البحرين وعمان والمملكة
اغراءات وحوافز جذابة. نعم. هكذا
اطلقت مجموعة فاغنر حملة تجنيد
صحيفة الالمانية. اما على الارض
فالجيش الروسي يعلن التقدم في
وقت التفاوض?
مخازن اسلحة حديثة لكن القوات
الاوكرانية من جانبها قالت انها
ان نزود اوكرانيا بالاسلحة التي
تحتاج اليها كي تنتصر. وذلك بحسب
وسبقتها منظومة هايمرس وباتريوت
الامريكية. رسائل تضامن قوية من
وبولندا امداد الاوكرانيين
بمنظومات مدفعية وارتال من
تقلهم شمالي البلاد. وذكرت
الشرطة الاوكرانية ان الحادث
الناتو بعد مماطلة لشهور بارسال
اسلحة سوفيتية فقط خشية اغضاب
مدينة باخموت مؤكدا انه على اكثر
من ثلاثمائة جندي اوكراني ودمر
العام ليوبخ بوتين وزيره بسبب
التباطؤ في امداد البلد
اسفر ايضا عن مقتل ستة عشر شخصا
اخرين. ليرد حلف الناتو فورا لقد
بالطائرات المدنية والعسكرية
تايلند تلعب دورا احمقي هذا
تحذيرات روسيا حيث قررت الولايات
المتحدة وبريطانيا وفرنسا
بسبب وجود مجموعة كاملة من
الاسلحة. هناك غضب الرئيس الروسي
فقد وصلت اول رسالة وذلك بحادث
مشبوه. اذ اعلنت السلطات
الاوكرانية عن مقتل وزير
الداخلية الاوكراني ونائبه اول
المشتركة انطلقت بطبيعة دفاعية
فقط وستركز على مهام الاستطلاع
القوات الروسية تحشيد قواتها
لتحصين مواقعها والتقدم في
وفنلندا. نفذوا ما قلنا لكم
حرفيا والا ماذا يا اردوجان
واجراء مناورات في كل الظروف
والتضاريس ليخرج الامين العام
روسيا وتعزز هذه المساعدات من
قدرات جيش اوكرانيا على القتال
ومجموعة من المسؤولين الرفيعين
اثر تحطم مروحيتهم التي كانت
روسيا تستعد بحرا وبرا. عام يبدو
قاسيا ومرعبا من بدايته من
الجانب الروسي ولا شيء يترك
للصدفة. نعم بحرا وبرا تحاول
من قبل اوكرانيا بينما اضاف
المجلس ان تدريبات القوة الجوية
وطهران ترد على تل ابيب بمقاتلة
روسية مرعبة.
الميدان الاوكراني. وجيش كييف
يقول ان موسكو عززت قواتها في
برية هائلة واوكرانيا هي الهدف.
وطائرة وزير الداخلية الاوكراني
تخر سريعة ليكون هو الضحية
والناتو يرسل ارتالا من الاسلحة
نعم نعم. صواريخنا في احشاء
منصات الاطلاق ونحن مستعدون للرد
جاسوس امريكي يجبر الولايات
المتحدة على التحرك في ايران
اعصابه ووزيره هو الضحية.
وواشنطن تلوح بالنووي لاجل اعين
للرد على سفينة بنتاجون يتحضر
لساعة الصفر ان حانت. بوتين يفقد